[Musique]
actuellement c'est la la journée de
présentation sportive des équipes sur le
départ de ce tour puisque on appelle
prologue c'est tout simplement une
course par équipe chronométrée qui
permet suivant les résultats donc les
temps réalisés par chaque équipe de
permettre de remettre les différents
maillots de leader pour que ces maillots
soiés demain au départ de la première
étape et ça permet également de donner
la place des voitures techniques dans la
caravane de course par ordre de
classement je crois que tous les
coureurs depuis le début de saison
partent pour dire je me prépare pour les
épreuves du dimanche mais aussi pour le
tour de l c'est l'ambition de tout les
cyclistes à la
[Musique]
Réunion
en fait ils sont C coureurs par équipe
et on est chronométré sur trois coureurs
donc le but c'est d'être homogène qu' il
y en a deux qui se sacrifient un peu
pour que après so il soit TR sur la
ligne d'arrivée quoi faut communiquer il
faut de l'entraînement en amont il faut
aussi que le coach il décide voilà qui
c'est qui démarre qui c'est qui fait un
gros relais qui c'est qui finit et c'est
l'entraînement tout simplement la
préparation donc là on voit qui est
préparé et qui est pas préparé quoi ah
ben nous espérons d'abord une belle
météorologie avec un soleil comme
aujourd'hui ce serait l'idéal pas de gr
pour les coureurs et je crois que au fil
des étapes nous aurons quand même des
différents petits col à traverser et
nous avons essayé de tracer ce ce tour
en cette étape avec des routes assez
signeuses qui permettrait au courur de
s'exprimer correctement que ce soit en
descente que ce soit en plat ou que ce
soit en monté je souhaiterais
effectivement que ce tour apporte une
bonne sportivité une bonne de bonnes
poiges dans la course qu'elle soit saine
surtout pour que le dimanche 5 octobre
nous soyons en apothéose avec du por et
le final